[Musik]
von der novartis privaten blog eines
klassischen zufall wer erfolg hat im
labor ist das sozusagen angebot des
erfolgs gehen viele andere dazu nur
selektiert aussage als bruch der mann
hätte wie pistole ziehen um mit viel
disziplin und ich glaube dann kommen wir
bis erreichen
meine und was dazu gehörten aber es
braucht immer wechselbrücken bier
braucht nicht wie wir pächter und wir
bauen
darum geht es in diesem film
das sind
ein
[Musik]
entropa das erreicht wovon viele träumen
er ist ausgewandert und erfolgreich
geworden
zusammen mit 32 arbeiten die meisten
davon heute bewirtschaftet er 180 hektar
land
group gehört zu den drei größten ananas
produzenten in der dominikanischen
republik
wobei jeder seine aufgabe hat die
arbeiter ihre der chef seine drei kinder
sitzt sehr viel ich danke er wieder mal
typisch dies lockt zu und die schwarze
schafe
das ist jetzt mal so ich hatte da nicht
soviel setzte aber das ist eigentlich
eine seele ich sage dir lieb für die
einen gurt wird als zusätzlicher sie
setzt also immer co und die ordner
dateien nicht - wie es sie schon der
prozent handarbeit und diese zahl ist
außerordentlich von jährige steuer
überhaupt eu-sicht hessischen arbeitet
man darf da nicht mit ihr tauschen sich
die leute mit der arbeit für die npd
wieder einen normalen arbeiter in einer
anderen fabrik geschafft das ist gut so
geordnet und drumrum das und das ist ja
falschen beruf da sind sie also 16 aus
den niederlanden
[Musik]
13 monate nach dem setzen werden die
ananas geerntet pro woche zwischen 50
und 60 tausend stück die besten
exemplare werden nach europa exportiert
wo sie in feinkostgeschäften verkauft
werden
unkonstante spitzenqualität garantieren
zu können kontrolliert regelmäßig
persönlich wie süß seine früchte sind
also mit ins andere tricks masse
hausbewohner anhand der werden jetzt
dritter komfort ist eine optimale 12
euro kapitalspritze durch normal und ist
mit 13,5 für mich also fürs überhaupt
keine probleme die sich hier daneben
verkauft in detroit
so probiert vertraut und kultur europas
wird
das spezielle an seinen ananas ist dass
sie ausgereift geerntet werden und
binnen weniger tage im verkaufsregal
stehen denn sie werden nicht verschickt
sondern per flugzeug exportiert
wir bekommen auf
und darunter auch einen druck oder
rückverfolgung garantie also das heißt
in deutschland ruft machte die bank
gesetzt worden ist
wer gesetz zu wählen
und alles dabei außer von
folge von einer reformation und das vor
das runde muss der gemeinschaft die
proben mit dass man eine rückverfolgung
verwandte und richtig dass diejenigen
ananas die nicht perfekt sind werden
locker verkauft hat auch sein gutes
geschäft
das geld verdienen und führen muss man
trieb nicht erklären
er hat es im betrieb seiner eltern von
klein auf gelernt und das ist
wahrscheinlich genauso wie mit den usa
weiter wo mir wahrscheinlich genauso
griechen und da weiß man ungefähr wie
miss muss für
[Musik]
die trupps waren gemüsebauern im zürcher
unterland wo sich 22 hektaren land
bewirtschafteten bissig emigriert anfang
der achtziger jahre entschloss hierher
auszuwandern
[Musik]
wieso haben sie eine quelle aus der
schnitt ist also klar ist aber ganz
ehrlich es ist das generationenproblem
sich war mir vorher eingeschnittenen aus
drei generationen betrieben mitternacht
das ist irgendwie einfach nicht
vorkommen heißt
dritte generation andere vorstellungen
zum produzieren wir sagen wir es wollten
und was ist eigentlich ein hauptproblem
war wenn man ganz elend sind es
generationenproblem in den 80er jahren
wanderten viele schweizer in die
dominikanische republik aus und kauften
formen von der gruppe in die ihnen das
blaue vom himmel versprach früher war
damals mitte zwanzig und teil einer
reisegruppe kaufwillige für 50 grad am
tag bekomme man hier einen arbeiter und
sei bald reich am morgen des achten
tages war der vertragsabschluss
traktandiert nachmittags freiwillig
früher blinde dankend ab er reiste drei
weitere male in die karibik bevor er
kaufte der mitgereiste karl feyerabend
ein schnapsbrenner aus dem kanton zug
war weniger clever er verlor seine
ganzen ersparnisse und trieb eineinhalb
jahre nach seiner auswanderung keine
rinderherde sondern lediglich ein paar
gänse vor sich hier
[Musik]
karl feierabends lebens und leidensweg
ist dem fernsehpublikum aus diversen
dokumentarfilmen bestens bekommt so wie
ihm ging es den meisten aus lebens
träumen wurden trümmer
[Musik]
trüb dagegen hat hier sein glück
gefunden er hat kein geld verloren
sondern verdient er hat schon drei
hyperinflationen überstanden und seinen
arbeiten immer pünktlich den lohn
bezahlt im gegensatz zu vielen anderen
machte er offenbar vieles richtig
sie haben einmal nicht von der materie
verstanden sie an gornik wisst was
eigentlich ihres zieles einer wand
stoffe oder sind seit dem umstieg aber
sie hat eine krimi was für ein land das
sie sich befindet wir nur um eine jetzt
schaffe die dunklen und ich muss nicht
mehr machen
ich werde an der chef da habe ich wollte
mit den worten immer durch dich und das
sagt dann immer durch worte
also man ist ohne respektiert werden
foto dominikaner vor honig jetzt doch
keine harmonie
ich muss mich bestätigen rund 300
franken zahlt club seinen arbeitern pro
monat fast doppelt so viel wie der
gesetzliche mindestlohn er versteht sich
als patron aus einem dem seine arbeiter
am herzen liegen
aus dieser heut jahre zu alt wurde für
die feldarbeit hat er ihm eine stelle
als nachtwächter angeboten außerdem
amtete er als pfarrer und seelsorger für
seine landsleute
[Musik]
in monte plata wenige kilometer von
seiner form entfernt besitzt aber auch
noch ein hotel mit restaurant das el
toro
angefangen hat er mit fünf zimmern
mittlerweile sind es 27
geleitet wird es von ewald trier bevor
sie sich in emil verliebte was
erfolgreiche bankerin
sie sei schlicht perfekt sagt ihr mann
eine frau die kein geld brauche sondern
helfe welches zu verdienen was ich da
nie wieder im familienunternehmen
ausgebildete buchhalterin
ich mache alles was mit zahlen zu tun
hat außerdem die ganze administration
und das personalwesen und ich kümmere
mich um alle rechts und steuerfragen
nein ich habe diese entscheidung noch
nie bereut ich fühle mich komplett
trittin an santo domingo eine tucker
maschine ab mitte seine leute schachteln
für den export fertigstellen
die altacher maschine funktioniert zwar
noch gabriel möchte nicht riskieren dass
die produktion unterbrochen werden
müsste
die dominikanische republik sei kein
land für träumer sagt er mir immer
wieder ab genau deshalb kommen
touristenort boca chica weil sie von
sonne sand oder lebensabschnitt
seelenverwandtschaft und träumen
[Musik]
das macht mir sorgen dass uns die leute
akzeptieren
irgendwie weiß sein damit auch sagen
dass gott hier unter direkter
entwicklungserfolge und diese woche die
leher bezahl app ist und weder dann ist
das eine sport nicht so schlimm wie
klicks in hörstel
warum
ich glaube ja dass entwicklungshilfe und
was gott sein eigentliches ist ein
freies land südamerikanische land ist
südland und ist im prinzip ist alles für
die einfache fahrt ohne und ich glaube
man gute schwitzen komplex hat darf und
ob und ohne ist der einfach nicht
oder er fühlt sich freier weg von
schwind
[Musik]
mit dem ersten licht beginnt auf trips
fahren der tag
[Musik]
mehr oder weniger weise primero war ja
immer am ball bleiben dem laptop auf mit
59 noch täglich nach
im moment lässt der teile seines landes
roten um weiter und damit mehr sehen zu
können
vor allem halunken die versuchen beute
zu machen auf den 30 hektaren auf denen
limiten anbaut
was machen sie da waren sind tief
gesehen die absicht im prinzip wie
schnitzel oder schon baumaßnahmen die
rettung bringen dann auf polizei und der
wehrhafte betrieben tätig später sogar
und der und einfach mit er hat mich zwei
jahre
das ist auch so hilft es vor und noch
lieber redet dann auch drüber schreibt
betrieben einen tick quasi länger und
wenn ja wie der user sieht also nach
zwei wochen schon wieder und wieder
stellt das ist also als lukratives
geschäft oder eine limette hat hier
einen wert von 10 rappen
einerseits geht es beim kampf gegen die
limetten kriminalität sei es um geld
andererseits gehe es aber auch darum
keine schwäche zu zeigen erklärt mir der
ananas könig muss man deutlich wie
hertie und wie kreml erfolg sicher
der frage was heißt das
verliert man respekt aber ich so ein
limone die channel in einem verschneiten
eigentlich nicht wer waffen und geld
verdienen oder wer sich der komiker
seinen job hat oder ganz abgeschafft und
im prinzip weniger für die entweder eine
wo unser klima gestellt um mehr verdient
mit hart aber fair
so sieht sie strömt
seinen ehrlichen mitarbeitern auf ritter
täglich ein frühstück kakao und brot
[Musik]
jede einzelne überstunde wird bezahlt
und das mittagessen das ein caterer
täglich gegen 12 uhr liefert geht auch
auf trips kosten der arbeiter wenn gut
dass der märkte zu schaffen
also es gibt bis um verlangen ich glaube
das kommt unter dem motiv und so habe
ich liebe und sie am nachmittag sind sie
immer noch fähig zum schaufahren zur
kasse hand fluktuationen gibt es kaum
seine form gilt als musterbetrieb den
delegationen aus dem in und ausland
gerne besuchen
mitsamt familie dürfen einige arbeit auf
trips form wohnen
in diesem fall in sichtweite zu seinem
sohn und dessen pferden stefan dreher
bis 19 studierte ingenieur agronom und
kommt nur noch jedes zweite wochenende
nach hause
er wird das alles einmal übernehmen
können im gegensatz zum sohn eines
landarbeiters wurde er in die richtige
familie hineingeboren
[Musik]
realistischerweise habe ich sicher einen
vorteil aber nur am anfang
ob das zufall oder schicksal ist kann
ich nicht sagen aber es ist ja
schlussendlich auch egal
du musst etwas daraus machen du musst
dein leben mit fleiß leidenschaft und
hingabe leben da muss glücklich sein
dein vater kann der reichste mann der
welt sein und sein sohn kann alles
wieder verlieren
die fachliche ausbildung sei das ein
erzählt mich sein vater genauso wichtig
sei es stefan auch charakterlich auf
seine aufgabe vorzubereiten
viele sicher sind meinem vater disziplin
und respekt wichtig wer will dass man
sich immer anstrengend dass man ziele
hat im leben und konsequent auf diese
ziele hinarbeiten dass man nicht so
schnell mit sich zufrieden ist
er hat mich nie unter druck gesetzt ein
nachfolger zu werden
er hat immer gesagt dass ich selber
herausfinden muss was ich gerne mache
nur so findest du dein glück und wenn du
nicht glücklich bist mit dem was du
machst du so machst du es dann
einen steinwurf entfernt feiern die
haitianischen arbeiter der drops
gottesdienst
[Musik]
wünsche hoffnungen und träume wohnen
überall
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben diese kirche gebaut um einen
ort zu haben wo wir gott für alles
danken können was wir von ihm bekommen
habe er hat uns das leben geschenkt er
hat uns gerettet
er schenkt uns seine liebe und eines
tages wird er uns zu sich ins paradies
wo das ewige leben auf uns wartet unter
dem gleichen himmel möchte sophie trier
13 eine restaurantkette aufbauen
stefan will pharma werden und evakuiert
und ihr mann wünschen ihre familie
gesundheit
[Musik]
zwischen all diesen wünschen hoffnungen
und träumen greifen die ananas einfach
weiter
in wenigen tagen werden diese früchte in
europa sei das ist eine tatsache
demetriou ist fest entschlossen jeden
tag die chance zu geben in noch
erfolgreicher werden zu lassen
das ist eine vermutung mit soviel
möglichkeit dazu möglich machen außer
hauptsache für mich ist der produktion
landwirtschaftlicher also das thema ist
schweiz konnte misserfolg als rambo
manier kreishaus lacht aber ich glaube
dass man nicht einfach war das heute
schweiz ihnen passieren die schweiz in
der folge
[Musik]